Bradley Cooper and Lady gaga joined
forces to give us a new take on the
classic love story a star is born which
follows a struggling young artist and a
veteran performer battling addiction
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm going to reveal 10
behind-the-scenes secrets and
fascinating facts about the making of
the newest star is born' movie make sure
you keep watching to the end to find out
the heartbreaking real-life story behind
Lady Gaga's final song the first time
Allie and Jackson meet she's performing
in a drag bar belting out Edith Piaf's
classic love song levy on Rose and
incredibly we have that famous French
tune to thank the director Bradley
Cooper's a star is born' movie as we
know it today because not only did the
song inspire the drag bar scene but also
crucially it inspired Cooper to cast
Lady gaga in the lead back in 2016
Cooper was still considering who should
play Allie when he was invited to
accounts the benefit in LA were the
superstar singer happened to be
performing Cooper found himself so
mesmerized by Gaga's rendition of La Vie
on Rose that he immediately decided to
include the song and Gaga in his movie
straight after the event Cooper got in
touch with her agent and set up a
meeting at Gaga's Malibu home where he
basically offered her the role there and
then the two videoed themselves singing
at the piano together and reading scenes
from the script which convinced the
studio that Cooper had indeed found his
perfect co-star and the rest as the star
is born' history oh and it was Gaga's
conversations with Cooper about her
early experiences in the music business
and a particular drag bar where she used
to hang out that gave him the idea to
create that particular scene during the
press tour for a star is born Cooper and
Gaga have talked often about the
immediate connection they felt as soon
as they met and how they bonded over
their East Coast italian-american
upbringing among other things and one
particularly sweet moment during the
shoot shows just what close friends they
became after Cooper it filmed an
especially tough scene which was vital
for his character he walked up to
Jackson's pickup truck and opened the
door only to discover a bunch of roses
that Gaga had left for him there on the
passenger seat if you've seen the movie
you'll understand why Cooper was so
moved by Gaga's gesture as the scene he
just filmed was a heartbreaking one for
Jackson the soundtrack to his star is
born' is jam-packed with original songs
some of which were actually written
during the shoot for example lady gaga
wrote the
I don't know what love is when she felt
completely overcome with emotion after
filming the scene in the cop bar and she
even used her character Ally's on-screen
notebook to write down the lyrics right
there in the moment
she later finished off the song with
Lukas Nelson's son of country music star
Willie Nelson Lucas not only wrote and
produced many of the movies original
songs with Gagarin Cooper but he and his
bandmates from promise of the real also
doubled as Jackson Mane's band in the
movie
Lady Gaga really hates watching movies
where you can tell the act as a
lip-syncing so despite the fact that her
co-star Bradley Cooper had no real
experience as a singer or musician
before a star is born she convinced him
to record all their vocal performances
live on the day of filming rather than
simply lip-synching to pre-recorded
tracks as often happens in movie
musicals although first time director
Cooper found singing live terrifying he
says it allowed him to capture the truth
in each performance
many of the movie's musical moments were
filmed at real venues like Glastonbury
Festival so to avoid the crowd recording
their brand new songs and leaking them a
line ahead of the film's release the
sound crew deliberately turned off the
amplifiers so the audience couldn't hear
the music or vocals that added another
level of work for the movie sound team
as they had to capture each venues
acoustics and apply them later in
post-production to make the voices sound
like they would have done during a big
concert using such enormous real-life
performance spaces like LA's Greek
Theatre and the Shrine Auditorium meant
the production needed lots of people in
the audience to get the right visuals
energy and enthusiasm to make the
concert look and feel real but instead
of using thousands of extras the
filmmakers instead turned to Lady Gaga's
dedicated fanbase known as her little
monsters who were given the chance to
buy tickets for each of the venues worth
filming took place all the proceeds from
which went to Gaga's Born This Way
Foundation and as an extra thank you to
her fans at the end of a late night
filming Gaga gave an impromptu piano
performance of two of her hits
Bradley Cooper may have many years
experience acting on camera but when it
came to playing a seasoned singer and
musician performing live on stage he
realized he needed to dedicate plenty of
time to preparing for the musical
aspects of the part so he got himself a
vocal coach and spent five days a week
for six months
how to sing not just as himself was also
in character as Jackson mane
to give you an idea of the kind of
progress cooper made with his singing
when he first started he found himself
getting out of breath after just one
verse so he certainly came a long way
from that to performing so many songs
live on film cooper also took guitar and
piano lessons and worked pretty much
every night for 12 months with lucas
nelson who also shared his own insights
on performing and acting like a
professional musician but cooper didn't
just work on his singing voice he also
spent months working on his speaking
voice using a dialect coach to help him
develop the rich tambour he wanted the
Jackson Mane's voice it proved to be a
real challenge and initially it was even
painful but Cooper felt that lowering
his range by about an octave would give
his character the kind of presence
iconic musicians have and cinema
audiences would feel that as soon as
they saw Jackson on-screen Cooper
dropped his own voice to more or less
match the register of actor Sam Elliott
who places on-screen brother and
apparently all that time Cooper spent
listening to interviews with Elliott to
hone his new voice paid off because when
he played a recording of himself during
his first meeting with Elliott's the
veteran actor was amazed at how much
Cooper's voice sounded like his own
although Gaga already has a Golden Globe
for American Horror Story a star is born
as her first lead role on the big screen
and it took a little while for her to
feel at home on set while she knew all
her lines on her first day of filming
she was so thrown when Bradley Cooper
went off script for a moment in an
effort to help her relax and let go of
the words that she just kept repeating
her same line again and again before
bursting into tears
Gaga and Cooper soon created a shorthand
between themselves though to get the
right mood for each scene for example to
conjure up a certain warmth in her
performance Cooper would say the name
Tony to remind Gaga of her great friend
and singer Tony Bennett who she adores
but if Gaga had to really concentrate
then Cooper would say ninja or assassin
just before Lady Gaga was due to film a
really big emotional scene on stage at
the Shrine Auditorium
she got a devastating phone call that
her best friend Sonya was dying of
cancer so she jumped in her car and
drove straight to Sonya's side though
she sadly missed her friend's passing by
just moments when Gaga later returned to
set she took to the stage and gave a
heart-wrenching performance of our novel
again an especially moving song for her
character Ally and a scene that Gaga's
says she'll never forget so have you
seen the newest tourist board movie and
what did you think of it I'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
tapleft to watch my next a star is born'
video or tap write for another video
you're sure to like and if you enjoyed
this video I really appreciate a thumbs
up and a share thanks for watching and
see you next time yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers